[Music]
okay let's go
black against 1552
all right expecting e4
and we get it well madagascar
knight f3 knight c6
and we are facing a scot well either a
scotch or a scotch gambit
depends on what white does here
yeah it's a traditional scotch
now four night scotch you will remember
is knight c3 knight f6 that's what we
play with white with the inclusion of
these two moves it's a four night scotch
now there are many systems which i can
recommend against the scotch but the two
main ones are knight f6 in this position
and the move that i recommend to most
players in the 1500 rating range is
bishop c5 i think this is very practical
it's relatively easy to learn and there
isn't
you know a vast amount of theory after
bishop c5 in fact white well white has
three moves yeah bishop b3
knight can drop back to b3 that's the
most rare and then knight takes c6
okay here it's very important to avoid a
blunder
a lot of people hear blunder just by
developing the knight
notice that the bishops are x-raying
each other so white's going to take on
c6 and then take on c5 and it's going to
be a free bishop
so black has two main moves here
you can either drop the bishop back to
b6
and obviously anchor it with the pawns
or
you can develop your queen to f6 this is
what we're going to do this is the other
main move
and of course this avoids losing a piece
because if knight takes c6 then we can
take on e3 and our queen's not going to
be hanging
so c3 is the main line our opponent is
following the main line
now the drawback of queen f6 of course
is that it takes away the f6 square from
the knight but that's not an issue and
we've been discussing this continuously
why is that not an issue
where can we go yeah xqc taking notes
where can we go with that knight
well we can go 97 yeah knight g7 is an
entirely viable developing move in fact
i like it because it connects the
knights now one thing couple of things
to notice first of all we shouldn't be
afraid
of this standoff
largely because if white ever takes on
c6 or moves the knight anywhere
we can take white's bishop on e3
that threatens checkmate on f2 and
forces white to recapture
and then we can either recapture the
knight or if black white's knight for
example has gone to b5 we can take on e3
and then we can take a tempo to defend
uh c7 now this is a mistake actually
knight takes c6 is a mistake play bishop
takes e3
we're threatening mate so f takes e3 as
force and that has completely
ruined white's pawn structure completely
ruined wein's pawn structure yeah
doubles pawns but it's not just any
doubled pawns right because quite
possibly we can play d takes c6
and double our own pawns but the it's
not so much the doubled pawns
as the fact of where they're doubled
they're doubled on the e file where
they're the most accessible they're the
easiest to target
and in addition if you think about it
after f takes e3 the possibility of
queen h4 check which itself is a fork
once we recapture the knight queen h4
will be a threat just to add to
everything here i think our opponent is
regretting it
what should we recapture with in fact
the funny thing is we can make a case
for all three pieces
there's actually four pieces we could
recapture with i don't like queen takes
c6 that doesn't make sense
now we can play i take c6 to preserve
the health of our pawn structure but i
also could see us making a case for dc
because that opens up the bishop more
rapidly and d takes c6
uh is the move i actually want to play i
feel like this is the most natural at
least to me because i really don't care
about these doubled pawns they're not
accessible they're not targets
and we streamline our development by
getting the diagonal of our bishop open
and because white's king is in the
center intuitively i feel like it's very
important for us to develop as quickly
as possible maybe we'll get a chance to
somehow win this game before white even
gets a chance to castle does that make
sense
so we are sacrificing a little bit of
pawn structure health for the sake of
quicker development
probably in against another gm i would i
would play knight takes c6 you're right
and then d6 but
for the sake of this game i feel like we
can have a little bit more fun okay
knight d2
yeah i'll talk about queen h4 first
after the game it doesn't work
tactically
um
well now queen h4 doesn't make sense
because if g3 and knight d2 is correct
it defends d4 pawn so
we i mean there's nothing special we
should do we can castle short we can
play bishop e6
but castling is probably the most
the most flexible developing move
because it's a move we know we have to
play anyway whereas we don't know
exactly where we want to position this
bishop maybe in some situations our
bishop will be able to develop to g4 for
instance if why did moved the queen to
prepare long castles we would have gone
bishop g4 okay there should be two so
white is not threatening to castle
important moment
what does that mean
well that means that we should keep the
queen on f6
and it also means that rook f1 is not a
serious threat okay white is not
threatening rook f1 in fact we want
white to play rook f1 because then he
permanently
loses castling rights
so we should make something resembling a
neutral move now
now that we know we we're not getting
our bishop to g4 i think the time has
come for us to play bishop e6 and
develop our bishop again not being
afraid of moves that attack your queen
that's very important rook f1 we go
queen h4 check and we win the pawn on h2
bishop f3 is a great move so our
opponent has managed to castle now
here we need to switch gears right
we need to switch from
preventing castles mode to adapting
our pieces to the new set of
circumstances white is going to castle
that is a bygone conclusion now what we
need
are good squares for our queen
because it's done its job on f6
we need a good square for our knight and
we need to figure out where we're
putting our rooks we have three things
to do
i see an arrangement of these three
pieces that i really like
uh
knight where should the knight go well
it makes sense for the knight to be on
e5 that's a really really juicy square
and it can get there pretty easily
where should our queen be
where should our queen be what's a nice
juicy square on the king side where the
queen is doing something but it's out of
the way of the other pieces
i'm not each same idea but h6 is a
little awkward i like g5 right g5 is a
little more central let's go queen g5
first because it attacks the pawn on e3
and it delays castling by another move
then we get our knight to e5
and how should our rooks be arranged how
should we arrange our rooks
simplest
question of all of the piece
arrangements this is very natural
rooks on d8 yeah rook should go but
which rook is the more important rook to
start with right let's start with well
of course we start with the knight
knight g6 but once we get the knights e5
once we get the knight to e5 which we
just did
we should start with the rook 88 because
we get the more bang for our buck rook
feat is
uh is like installing
i don't know it's like do you
do you you bought a house or whatever
are you renting an apartment no
furniture do you install the tv first or
you know do you get a bed well it's more
important to sleep than to watch tv
although
if you saw how i lived you'd probably
think the opposite um but rook 88 is the
more important part rook fe-8 will play
if we have time for it and if we have
the need
wrong yeah see that was a bad example
because we actually actually more
important to have the tv
yeah the computer goes first
open file yeah and again this is the
situation what do i always tell you guys
when you have a situation with only one
open file it is crucial that you are the
one occupying it or at least that you're
contesting it other things to notice
alignment of the queen and the rook i'm
already noting that down in case white
plays knight b3 which is not impossible
maybe our opponent will get the bright
idea to improve the position of his
knight we will immediately have bishop
c4 pinning the queen of the rock right
these are things that i note
before they happen right i'm already
aware of them which greatly increases my
tactical vision b3 okay that's
obviously not a scary move it doesn't
accomplish much now bishop c4 is not
possible but that's fine
let's get a rook to d8 and notice how we
devised
uh proper piece arrangement and then we
just put all our pieces where we wanted
them to not rocket science rook 81
now in playing the move b3 what i do
notice is that c3 is now quite weak so
we have a really really nice move i
think it's quite natural and i believe
that we already win material what am i
talking about
using our knight on e5 as an anchor
of course rook d3 brilliant i mean look
at this look at this positional
domination
and every one of white's pieces is
terrible now knight c4 by the way is an
interesting attempt here to diffuse the
tension but it doesn't work who can tell
me what the most precise
response to knight c4 is
because of course rook takes c3 as
possible
um
but
what is the most dominant answer to that
no no not rook takes c3 their knight is
on c if knight c4
yeah we want to play bishop takes c4 we
want to take that knight with our bishop
but not with our knight our knight wants
to remain on e5
so visualize knight c4 bishop takes c4
and if rook takes d3 we can play bishop
takes d3 and we win everything
and if b takes c4 then we can very
calmly take on c3 or on e3 and start
mopping up all of the pawns
so white literally is just totally caged
in totally caged and we can start taking
pawns right nothing wrong with taking
some material when you've established
positional domination
this everything we did so far should
make perfect sense i mean it's been
pretty damn pretty darn straightforward
there we go knight c4 how do i decide
that the bishop takes well
honestly taking with the knight here
just blunders the exchange
and i want to avoid
actually
well i want to avoid taking on d1 if i
can
because just because i don't want to
give away this beautiful rook on d3 that
rook on d3 is the piece responsible for
taking all of white's pawns right so i
just want to keep it there if possible
bishop takes c4
now there's multiple approaches after b
takes c4 we can i think take either pawn
with either piece we can play queen
takes e3 and get a queen trade that
makes sense
we can play rook takes e3
um or we can play rook takes c3
i think it really doesn't matter which
pawn to take my inclination is toward
rook takes c3
my inclination is to take on c3 we don't
need to play our cup to gate right
we don't need to at some point you have
to decide when that moment is it's time
to convert your positional advantage
into a material event there's no need to
make any further improvements the time
has come for us to start taking pawns
another important thing look at this
knight on e5 and what it does not only
is it just sitting on white's position
it's also preventing rook d7 shenanigans
so we don't have to worry about white
having control of the d file not anymore
there are more important things now in
particular us taking all of white's
pawns is more important all right
we use the d file as a jumping off point
now we're just taking all of white
spawns this is completely resignable
the one thing we didn't have time to do
here which i would have loved to do is
to create lift
and if you want to create luft in the
nicest way
i would not even play h6 i would play g6
and then perhaps h5 i'm sure you've seen
this kind of arrangement of pawns g6 f7
h5
what's up unconventional 24 months
welcome
and and that even further restricts the
bishop on f3
yeah queen e3 rookie 3 rxe4 it doesn't
matter we just take all of white's pawns
um
rook d-e-1
well he defends e3
we the funny thing is we don't even have
to rush we don't have to rush with rook
takes c4 but at the same time i don't
see a reason to wait but let's just take
another pawn and then we can continue
beautifying our king side g6 h5
bring the other rook to d8 whatever we
want to do this is the winning
another thing to look out for is forks
right very often in such positions
you'll see a move like queen b2
or queen f2
and we should at least be aware that the
knight can jump into d3 with potentially
a fork
okay so now if we want to really
display the extent of our domination
if we really want to just sink our teeth
into white's position what's up thank
you unconventional
what should we do we really want to just
tighten the screws completely
right h3 is another weakening move what
does it weaken
well it weakens the g3 square let's sink
our queen onto that square
we keep putting off the the making of
luft but
there keeps being something more
juicy that we can do
bishop g4
okay
okay so this is the perfect moment i
think to play g6
this is the perfect moment to play g6
because maybe white wants to play work
out five here
and at least white has an inkling of
activity we don't even need to take on
e4 now remember i talked about the
concept of diminishing returns when it
comes to material
the first two pawns you take
are the most important right when you're
up two pawns that's a big material
advantage the difference between being
up one pawn versus two is a lot bigger
than the difference between two pawns
and three and so on that and that is
true for all
material right if you're up a bishop
that's huge
but the difference between being up one
bishop and two bishops is a lot less
than being up nothing versus being up a
bishop right
so this pawn and e4 is now less
important than other things about the
position such as preventing the rook
from coming to f5 because that makes
sense
and on the next move if we if we want we
can take on e4
but there is no exact science when it
comes to deciding which material to take
which material not to take right don't
look for an algorithm like this is
exactly how i know whether to take
another pawn it's it's a judgment call
you're it's a feeling right i feel like
rook takes e4 is maybe not the best that
we can do
and it doesn't matter of course it's
also winning completely no question
about it everything is winning here
yeah the po well it's not that it makes
the pawn less valuable it makes the pawn
more takeable right
what this pawn being so so bad tells me
is that we can take it essentially when
we want to
now what did i tell you guys about forks
i told you to
keep a very very very close eye
out
for um for potential tactical ideas and
if you have your eyes open
and you should see that rook four
creates a type one sorry a type two
undefended piece on e1
so there's a queen on e2 that's
defending it there's a queen that's
aiming at it
and a combat combining the concept of a
fork with the notion of deflection
yields knight d3
simple right queen d3 queen e1
and otherwise we take one of the rooks
simple simple enough
we could have also got rook c2 by the
way rook c2 is a good move too rook c2
and then we win
e1 and then e3
okay
rook f1 was also possible but then we
had queen c3
rook c1 roxy iii anything is winning
here
if we want to go for blood though we
should go rook c1 and just try to
checkmate him along the first rank
gg that was an instructive game i think
that that really shows you how effective
good positional play can be because this
game lasted 23 moves
and i think a lot of players at this
rating range of 15 1600 have this idea
that oh if i play positionally that
means
a 70 move game where you're
you know exploiting some tiny
imperfection in your opponent's
structure that's not what it is queen
b3 and if we want to end with a flourish
ladies and gentlemen
if we want to end with a flourish the
way we should think about this is this
okay
this would be checkmate under what set
of circumstances
under what set of circumstances would
this be checkmate
in fact under what circumstance there's
one thing that has to happen
we have to control
the g3 square
now i'm sure that if you've spent enough
time playing chess you know that if
there's a pawn on h4 that's the easiest
way in such situations to control the g3
square h4 h5 h4
yeah i saw bishop e6
um i saw bishop e6
and i
i calculated a really cute line now
don't try this at home i don't know why
i'm doing this video this is really
funny so
what do we do
if i were you guys i would just go rook
c3 here and win but because i'm me i'm
gonna try to win this as precisely as
possible no not quit h1
ignore it right ignore the bishop we
don't in fact we probably get mated if
we take it
so just play h4
bishop takes f7 check but we have to be
very careful here and we have to find
the right way to sidestep the checks our
opponent is probably not even gonna do
it but
okay no he is
where should we go
and you need to figure out the proper
sequence here
not king h8 because
notice that if you step to h8 or g7
although that move wins you allow the
queen to come back to b2 with a nasty
check
king h7
and where is the king ultimately going
what is the hiding spot what is the
hiding spot after bishop takes g6 check
or bishop g8 check
the hiding spot okay well this this
makes it easy because we simply take the
rook but
okay well now now we can obviously now
we can take the bishop because this is
not scary we have two extra rooks we can
easily deflect the checks but the hiding
spot would have been h6
if if he had gone bishop to hg6 we took
our king away on h6
this is what i had been going for and
there are no more checks
there are no more checks white has to
play rook takes h4 and give up another
rook
again completely unnecessary i would
normally not do this but i just figured
this was a good way to illustrate this
concept of bringing the pawn to h4 thank
you for the five karna
okay gg
um
yeah so bishop c5 is what i recommend
the system with bishop c5 queen f6 i'll
have a video on it eventually obviously
uh there's many systems actually and
this is already a mistake sort of
forgetting about bishop takes e3
all right so before i was really
interrupted bishop takes e3 and tremezo
the main move by the way here
if you check opening explore is bishop
out to c4 simply keeping the tension
and now there's 95 now you can do this
on your own you can check this check
this line out
but this is a very well studied
theoretical variation of black is
supposed to be fine here this is equal
um
so bishop e3 fe3 dc this move hopefully
makes sense we get our bishop out
knight d2 castles
yeah and here we come up with a an ideal
arrangement of pieces right we just sort
of manually look at all of the pieces
that have not been developed and we find
good squares for them
and the more experienced you are the
easier this process is
right quinn on g5 bishop on e6
knight goes from g6 to e5
and then what's up amanda then what
comes to d8
right easy easy enough and this is not
insane
and i have an example of this from one
of capo blanca's games
this is what inspired me to
to teach in this way right this concept
of
having in mind not necessarily a plan
because plan kind of
i think implies
one particular piece going somewhere
but this is a general piece
configuration you don't always get the
opportunity to do this right you only
get the opportunity to really do this in
a situation where your opponent is
incredibly passive and can do nothing to
stop you from arranging your pieces in
an ideal way
but those situations don't occur
infrequently like they they occur more
frequently than one might realize
so this is capo blanco or gozen and this
is a good example of devising and then
following through on a piece
configuration
so basically this is
a position in which white is obviously
playing for a win cabo blanca has an
extra pawn it's the extra eight pawn
so let's
reverse engineer
the winning plan
now how is white going to win this game
ultimately well probably by pushing the
a pawn that's a pretty damn safe bet
white's going to push the tape on at
some point
well what's stopping us from pushing
that pawn right now
well it's the fact that black is a rook
on a7 that's stopping the pawn from
moving
so carbonblanca says i need to somehow
use all of the pieces at my disposal i
need to arrange them in such a way
that will ultimately allow me
to get my king all the way to the k to
the queen side and help this pawn
uh help the spawn advance
so
first he says where should this knight
go that's the first question this knight
in f3 does it have a nice
central square that it can go to
it does right it does it has d4
nice solid square
rook b7
okay next this pawn on b2 does it have a
good square thank you half nba it does
before
how about
the king what is the fastest and most
efficient way of involving the king how
do we do that what do we do here
we go not king f1 that's not the most
efficient we go f4
so we grab
sorry we go f4 we grab some space we
control the e5 square that's great
and we involve the king via f2
and last part of the puzzle where should
the rook go
how should the rook
no you need to defend the a3 pawn but
you can't you need to make sure that
white stroke is still active while it's
doing it
so a lot of you would make the mistake
of going rook a1 here this is a very
instructive mistake don't do that why
don't rooks be long behind past pawns i
hear you say well this is an exception
to the rule the reason is that you're
going to have a very very hard time
pushing the a pawn because black is a
bishop controlling a4 so you need to be
a lot more patient than that in the
meantime your rook is now going to be
permanently tied down to the a3 pawn do
you see what i'm saying it's not it
doesn't have any mobility won't be able
to do anything else you can't afford to
do that because it's an end game you
need to make sure your pieces are
playing to their full potential
therefore you defend it from c3
and what this allows you now to do and
look rook d3 there we go there's the
rook multitasking defending a3 and by
threatening discover check it's forcing
the king back to e7
now comes the final piece of the puzzle
it's time to activate white's king king
e3
he goes rook back to c3 tying whoops no
he does not do that
he repeats moves once to gain time
now he goes back to e2 with his knight
why the heck does he do that
where is white's king eventually going
who can tell me where is white's king
ultimately going to end up
it's going to end up on the b file
somewhere on the b file watch rook d3
check
first you go king d4
then another check
now using tactics to reinvolve the
knight knight c3 look at this rook takes
a 394 check as a discovery beautiful
conversion f5 by rogozin trying to
control the square and now using tactics
once again to make progress who can tell
me what capoblanca did here this is the
decisive idea
this is the decisive idea that
capoblanco applies here
remember that rook takes a3 is not a
threat folks because of 94 check nothing
happened to this move
what can we do we play b5 very good
rook takes a3 94 chuck wins the exchange
and after rook a8 we finally we go king
c4 he could have gone a4 first it
doesn't matter king c4
king b4 finally he accomplishes what he
set out to do the king has made its way
to the queen side which means
that you can simply push the a pawn all
the way to a6 and win the game easily
out of desperation rogozin goes c5 check
and after on passat the game is
basically over white is now two pawns up
you can't take because you drop the
bishop
and the rest is pretty easy bishop g8
knight b5 check
and capoblanca's rook infiltrates to d6
with decisive effect look at these pawns
and how weak they're going to be
the game ends pretty quickly
he just ends up hunting down some of
white's king side black singing side
pawns
knight t4 stopping f3 just preventing
all counter play this is capablanca for
you
and in this position or goes and
resigned because
none of the pawns can be stopped
and i think this is a good example of
sort of setting out to accomplish a
particular piece configuration this game
is to be found in a book called endgame
strategy by sharochevsky originally a
russian book
like you look at this position you could
get easily overwhelmed i don't see a way
to make progress right i don't see how
you push this pawn because you can't
even push this one
but very methodically by improving every
piece
combo blank eventually found a way to
set this pawn in motion
so
going to c6
is not a great idea
well actually it is but black stops you
from going to c6 or goes and played
bishop d7 so
otherwise yeah knight c6 would have been
interesting to to prevent the rook from
coming back to a7 here you don't want to
allow the rook trade because
uh the knight is better than the bishop
in this position
does that make sense
yeah carpal blanca did not have much to
learn from and this is one of many
impressive end game displays
what makes the knight better well i mean
it's just the fact that the knight is in
the center it's dominating over the
position the bishop doesn't have
anywhere to be it's just sort of
passively sitting there and the only
thing it's doing is preventing white
from pushing the pawn which is a pretty
important task mind you but that's all
it's doing right it's just sort of
passive for lack of a better word
okay back to the game
now this is a much simpler piece
arrangement that we put together in our
game than capo blanca did in his game
but it's the same general approach
um
rook d3 and once rook d3 happens the
game is over now we just win all of
white's pawns there was only one thing
that i wanted to talk about
which is why didn't we play queen h4
check as some of you were suggesting
followed by queen take c4 this looks
very enticing we fork the knight in the
rook who can answer this question for me
just use tactical vision
yeah a savage muffin you can ask your
question while people are answering this
one knight takes c7 yeah
and if you just count the pieces guys
first of all knight d5 is possible
second of all knight takes c8
and this is a mess i mean two pieces for
a rook why get into this
white it's going to go knight d2 and
then castle long it's unclear
knight b1 has the focal rook takes e3
the e3 pawn is also hanging
the 997 is the forward prospects with
the pawn and e4 must progress by way of
g6 or c6 and from either of the squares
you can reach e5 our opponent offered us
an opportunity to perform two actions at
once
i'm not sure this saves a tempo
i understand what you're saying a savage
muffin
i actually am very impressed with your
logic here and i would go so far as to
say that it really doesn't matter as
much
whether your pawns on d6 or c6 i'd yeah
maybe you're right i mean knight c6 95
and then you want to go d6
it's it's very similar i think you're
probably right knight takes c6 is
marginally better for that reason
yeah no there's nothing wrong with their
logic but
it's just that but the only thing i
would say is that the d th d take c6
you're what you're missing is that d
takes e6 also opens up the d file and we
benefit from the d file so it's a tit
for tat situation that's that's the last
factor
that we benefit from the event of dc
so it's
both moves are possible that's why i
suggested that
well well said though that's exactly how
you should approach these positions good
good stuff i just like the idea of
getting well yeah e5 is just such a if i
may
i don't know if i can use the word sexy
in a the youtube superior yeah it is a
nice it is a nice square sexy square
well this game was one he already here
like i already hear the white's position
sucks with these pawns being as weak as
they are
and white having this dumb light scored
bishop
it's the combination of these factors
that makes it so hard to play this with
white
[Music]
you